man I've thrilled to call a good friend
one of the all-time greats in the
history of the sport charles woodson how
are you Charles well now how are you
what was that like
on Sunday man man it was a you know a
lot of fun for you know somebody who you
know played in that Stadium you know who
wore the silver and black for 11 seasons
you know it was a you know a pretty
special occasion for myself to be able
to come back and like the torch you know
it was it was just unbelievable man you
should have saw her should have saw the
parking lot before the game you know a
lot of fans that were there early packed
in man you know ready you know to go
support their team and it was a pretty
you know special moment and then the end
of the game well did the air just
absolutely exit the building like that
Charles yeah yeah man you know I think
you know you watch the game you know the
Raiders had it pretty much in control
you know for most of the game and then
all of a sudden you know like you just
you know stated you know kind of out of
the air and let out of the you know
Stadium I think everybody was
anticipating you know having that moment
you know winning the last game and it
kind of film and all of a sudden man it
seems like you know last couple minutes
of the game and you know they go down
and score and you know it was just man
you know I think that was that was rough
you know for for you know all of the
fans in that Stadium and I don't think
they knew how to react after you know
the final score well it sounded like
there were some boos for Derek Carr to
be honest with you Charles that would
talk about awkward and and and something
that for for a guy who's given his heart
in his soul and maybe not all the time
stellar play but it was awkward there
was no other way to put it for that
yeah certainly and a very disappointed
you know that that happened disappointed
for anybody who would have been you know
boring for Derek Carr
you know he's got it goes out there man
and he puts it all out there on the line
with you like his player I don't like
this play it doesn't matter he goes out
there and plays hard and I saw clips of
him after the game you know shaking fans
hands walking around and giving his
things and you know I don't think that
was necessary so for anyone to do if
they were directing to that directing it
at Derek I thought he made the biggest
play in the game at the end of the game
I was you know he ended up getting was
basically penalized for you know the
play that he made and getting down out
of bounce and you know giving this his
team a chance to win that game and all
of a sudden you know you go from the
first down and I'm probably the 22
backed up so yeah you know I'm not no -
please about the way that happened
because I know that kid man he's a good
kid and certainly don't desert that yeah
I know you spoke with him as part of NFL
the grind that's tonight how'd you find
Gruden I mean obviously he's your first
coach in the NFL and you've known him a
long time how did you find him
what would you how would you term him
when when you chatted with him after a
team that went six and four and had so
much in front of them and is now six and
eight Charles yeah I think he was it was
you know he had a lot of high hopes for
the team you know they they were playing
well and you know to to away games you
know Jets and then in Kansas City and
the scene seems like things just kind of
unraveled a little bit I know they
thought this was this season you know
again had high hopes but I know that
they knew it would be a tough season but
things were looking pretty bright you
know into those couple of weeks and then
this last game you know I know he was it
was important for him to go out and put
a short good showing on that last game
you know and to get to win for the fans
I know he was you know certainly doing
everything he could
his power to get that win but I just
think you know for for everybody you
know it's been it's been a long season
you know you find yourself now having
lost you know three three straight and
you know nobody can believe right now
that at this point after things were
looking so good
Charles what's in here on the Rich Eisen
show I'm gonna put it right in your in
your bread basket here Charles I give
you Derek Carr or I give you the field
of any other quarterback in on the
planet right now the starter for the
2020 Las Vegas Raiders week one is going
to be who I think it'll be Derek are you
do that I don't see the movement yeah I
don't think they're I don't see them
moving on from their car at this point
I mean yeah I just I don't see that I
don't see that scenario why why didn't
why all right now I could accurate I
could see I could see the team you know
getting the new another quarterback
maybe through the draft or whatnot you
know maybe to come in and bring some
competition but Derek Carr is a good
quarterback I mean I don't I don't see
how anybody would see otherwise and I
don't see how you know at this point you
know you would come to that anybody
would come to the conclusion you know
that there wouldn't be the quarterback
well the reason why the reason why I
asked though okay is because uh you know
Gruden I mean he's Gannon called the
game right he's in the booth and and
Brad Johnson won a Super Bowl with him
and other than that you know any this
may be unfair to say but the sense you
get he said Gruden is constantly looking
for quarterbacks other than them who he
actually likes and he appreciates I'm
wondering what you could fill me in on
his relationship or his thoughts on on
Derek Carr Charles well yeah everybody
knows the Gruden is the Gruden grinder
you know I mean he's he's tough on
quarterbacks and he was certainly that
way we're risk and when I was there I
mean it was always instances of him and
brisk endings going at it nobody but
Rich Gannon was you know a tough
quarterback a good quarterback and he
would give it as good as he
it sounds like Derek Kerr said again is
that right he gave it back to Gruden
note that no doubt you know there would
be times when he would be you know fed
up with it and you know he would have to
come back but I mean that's the way
their relationship worlds but I think he
got the best out of Rich Gannon
you know because their relationship was
the way it was and and I'm sure again
and appreciated it because we had yeah
the best years you know they're in
Oakland I believe the same tanker people
cook we could say the same thing could
happen to Derek Carr and I think if you
give up on him too soon I don't think
you'll be able to you know get the best
out of them and when I look at this when
I look at the team and there's far more
than Derek that's on that field you know
I mean there's a lot of things that go
into a team you know it's not just one
player who has you know in a position
where you're not winning games you know
again they were up 16 to 3 and a lot of
that was because of what you know Derek
Carr was out there doing yes and so gave
up you know a long drive late in the
game defensively
so everybody is to blame you know for
anything that doesn't go well on a team
and I know Derek Carr can play the game
of football so again I mean I I stand
behind the kids play and I think it's
been he's done very very well for the
Raiders Charles Woodson here on the Rich
Eisen show before we move on to college
football where you are spending your
first year as an analyst with Fox Sports
the best team you've seen so far whether
in person or watching on TV in in 2019
in the NFL would be which one
that's one yeah well I think we're in
person of course you know the best team
I I saw was you know up in Ann Arbor you
know in our Stadium in watching our team
go up against their rival you know I
watched that game and you know Westar in
particular you know their running game
and the offensive line you know I think
they you know they far outweighed our
defensive line and kind of pushed those
guys around throughout the game and made
things easy you know for their running
back whether who had a field day and
then Justin fields I thought quarterback
Wiseman I thought all season long he was
as steady as any quarterback in the game
and and I just helps you know to me I
have one visual of him and that's him
going into the tent and you know had a
knee
you know evaluated and then he comes out
of the tent and the very next play he
throws a touchdown
you know that you know that's the kind
of thing when you play this game you
know how tough it is how hard it is go
out there and played through injury you
know to see a kid do that that was
pretty special
now when you were by the way first of
all great way to talk about the Buckeyes
without saying their name I really
appreciate that I thought I picked up on
that Charles were you were you sitting
next to urban watching that game was
that happening were you with him yeah
yeah part of it absolutely I think
especially especially late in the game
as we're getting ready to do our
postgame you know I was sitting next to
him and you know what do you say what do
you say to a guy who to a guy who was
setting a know against you and then all
of a sudden you sitting next to him and
they're going for ain't no and your team
was out there getting spanked you know
that that's an uncomfortable position to
be well Charles I broadcast the draft
with Urban Meyer in Chicago a few years
ago on night to win Ohio State set the
record for most draft choices in the
first three rounds of an NFL Draft and
Michigan and yet to have a single player
drafted and every single time I looked I
could look down I look down the set he
gave me a smile
I don't know if it was out of sheer
pity was the only word for it he gave me
his number he said hey I'll come on your
show any time and he did he actually did
so he's a man of his word
that was not fun that was awful and so I
feel you Charles but you do that but you
knew that no so what I guess then the
doors open here wonderful what can be
done to get Michigan back on this
footing that we know that you know that
you that you had them on in the mid to
late 90s but what what can be done as
their signing day is beginning to roll
in a little bit today Charles well for
me I think no just in particular as I
looked at the last football game that we
play it out there at home you know the
first half of that game you know for one
we couldn't stop the run you know all
day which okay you know that that
happens that time but when you're
playing a team and they're able to run
the ball like like the way the Buckeyes
we're able to run the ball you have to
make them go the long way so yeah if
they can run the ball you let them get
five here maybe three there but you make
them go to a long way what we continue
to do in that game whenever we're
playing those guys we continue to give
up big plays and then when we have
opportunities make plays we kind of
squander them off and you know just
going through the game I'll remember
they they scored they scored you know
they scored the first we scored the
first touchdown we scored a touchdown
here six or seven we missed the extra
point and then and then we go to a you
know we couldn't get out to see it on
third down then we finally got off the
field on third I would come in as fourth
inside you'll do jump offsides on a punt
that paint gifting the ball back and
then the very next play I used to throw
up
you know 50-yard pass down the field I
think it went down to the to the two or
three or what yard and then down
ran it in and then ran it in then we
have a touchdown at the end of the half
we dropped we dropped the pass once we
get to the ground so we've had
opportunity after opportunity and then
enriched we're on the ground and we run
tired people shoo and we get a hospital
unsportsmanlike conduct like like
against against a great team you cannot
make mistakes and you have to capitalize
on all of your money or your
opportunities and so for me I think
that's first thing for our team is that
the big moments they have to they have
to make the play and they cannot make
mistakes I'm not I'm not for you know
anyone saying that we don't have talent
on the team we certainly have talent on
our team but in those moments you got to
have somebody in the middle of the field
when the ball is thrown deep you got to
be able to make the plays you know that
that are there for you to make so that
would that would be first and foremost I
would emphasize that if I was the coach
going forward until I was blue in the
face
Charles what's in here on the Richardson
show that said I just have a feeling
Davos just sitting there in Clemson just
he's got these guys I mean how can a
team that's a national champion that's
defending it and didn't lose a game have
the ability to say nobody believes in us
and play that card which he's doing he
is do I mean he's playing that card
every day and I would if I was everybody
else I'd look out for him and that team
what say you Charles yeah I think so too
I mean I mean anything could get credit
to dabble and their teams what they've
done over the you know course of the
last you know four or five years I mean
incredible football teams I think where
people not Clemson is is really not any
fault of their own but it's the schedule
you know their schedule was pretty
favorable I mean they played the last
month and a half or so and and hadn't
played a team that was ranked and like I
said there's no spark of their own they
just they just have to go out and win
and I think if I think people were we're
looking for you know Clemson to maybe
drop one game all the scenarios where if
they were to drop a games and they were
at it so it was like people were looking
for that team to drop off somewhere and
they are they find themselves back in
the championship the playoffs and when
the opportunity to go to the
championship game again also give those
guys a lot of credit you know they have
to take you know some of that heat so
people saying hey they're not that good
look at who they played and and all that
good stuff but we'll see what happens at
the end of the season and they'll have
their testers certainly you know stick
to everybody if they if they win another
one last couple of minutes for Charles
Woodson here on the Richard show were
you at the Heisman or you had to tap out
of that to go to Oakland were you at
both did you do both yeah yeah I did
both man it was a eventful weekend so I
flew out there to Oakland and I did the
show for the grind yeah Thursday Friday
and I shot the New York Friday night I
was at the - Saturday and I shot back to
Oakland on Sunday morning man so I could
be a part of be a part of that historic
moment who did you vote for in the
Heisman I voted for I voted for the
three guys for the guys everybody I was
there rich that's what I bought it for
are you saying that cuz you don't want
to say or you're not allowed to say are
you not allowed to say no I'm just
trying to have a little okay because I
was about to say they gave you the
trophy man they're not gonna take it
back you know what I mean they can't
take it they can't take it but no for me
I know being able to see fields and in
person like I said I thought he was
impressive impressive as a player that I
had seen that season I went with field
and then I went borough and third was
chase you go chase younger GOI Jalen
hurts I loved his story Charles I loved
his story and LSU fans who are obviously
euphoric right now that's kind of like
the last guy that they want to see from
the days in Alabama obviously that's not
Alabama walking through the door it is
Oklahoma you never know but I love
his stick-to-itiveness I love everything
about Jalen hurts I think he is gonna
knock it out of the park at the combine
and I cannot wait to see what he has in
store I love that kid man I think I've
never met him but I just loved watching
what yeah watch of him all season and
you know the way he would conduct
himself after games after wins and you
know just straightforward you know
businesslike approach man you never gave
people what they wanted he just you know
stuck his nose you know to the grind so
to speak man and just kept on going
forward and just like you say man his
story and especially with you know
playing for Alabama being a champion at
Alabama and then kind of run out of
there and help them you know go to
another school and and now he has
another chance to take another school
you know to a national championship I
think it's a pretty cool story so have
you ever talked to Peyton about beating
him in the Heisman Trophy do you ever
bring that up has that ever come up in
conversation Charles with Peyton Manning
and you know it has no okay not I don't
know why only I only have conversations
back and forth with you know people on
Twitter okay he's not on Twitter I know
that for sure but you did when it all
comes down to it be a professional and
be somebody who is a Heisman Trophy
winner who gives it to who he thinks is
best and does not play any favorites or
biases you go ahead and you you voted
for an Ohio State Buckeye that's what
you did Charles fact yes that happened I
don't I give credit to where credit is
due
and you know who I think is the best you
are you are the best
lovie Charles Woodson thanks for calling
in by the way so as you saw as you saw I
popped open the intercept line the other
day it is so good the Chardonnay pop
that one open no I don't drink a lot of
white but that is some good stuff you're
making Charles yeah man 90 points on
wine enthusiast for the Chardonnay 92
points for the Pinot Noir man so I
always appreciate your support Norma
sharing those moments with with me when
you're when you're passing a bottle that
are in
why always Charles you the past will
chat soon okay man thank you guy that's
charles woodson you're on the Rich Eisen
show for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app